il y a près d'un siècle un paquebot
immense et luxueux larguer les amarres
sur ce qu'est avec à son bord plus de
2000 passagers
surnommé l'insubmersible le rms titanic
est l équivalent du boeing 787
dreamliner de son époque
son destin tragique donnera naissance à
des histoires de légende
j'ai voulu inclure ces événements écrin
dans un contexte émotionnel moche on
craint taxe se servir de cette tragédie
comme arrière-plan et très intelligent
ce film est-il simplement l'histoire
tragique d'un navire de luxe flambant
neufs vous et a sombré par 4000 mètres
de fond
ou est ce une vision hollywoodienne de
ce désastre
destiné à attirer les foules sans aucun
doute un peu des deux
ce n'est pas un énième film sur le
titanesque et le trahissent et
simplement le décor d'un triste c'est
symbolique
on connaît l'impact que ça use les films
ne peuvent être entièrement fidèle à
l'histoire est d'ailleurs l'histoire
elle même n'est jamais complètement
fidèle à la réalité
nous passons le plus clair de notre
temps à la rue visiter et à la voir sous
des angles nouveaux
cela n'a jamais été aussi vrai que pour
l'histoire fascinante du titanic
le titanic exerce encore une grande
fascination sur notre imaginaire cent
ans après sans doute parce que son
histoire ressemble un grand roman qui
serait devenu réalité
le titanic a largué les amarres à midi
avec le capitaine smith aux commandes à
destination de new york
d'accord bien sûr on le sait il n'y
parviendra jamais la cohabitation des
riches et des pauvres
la constance et la noblesse d'un âge
révolu le faste de ce navire sublime à
l'échelle de la folie des hommes qui
l'ont poussé à plein régime dans
l'obscurité de l'océan est avant tout
cette conclusion que l'on doit en tirer
l'avenir est incertain et imprévisible
l inimaginable possible
c'est incroyable cher ce bateau a une
vie extrêmement courte annecy n'a coulé
il ya 120 ans qu'est ce qui reste encore
aujourd'hui le bateau le plus célèbre du
monde mais alors suivez-moi nous
tenterons d'y voir clair dans cette
tragédie qui semble parfois
incompréhensibles on ne peut oublier
cette partie de l'histoire et james
cameron a fait de cet événement un
morceau de l'histoire du cinéma
[Musique]
le titanic était immense et flambant
neuf tous rêvé de monter à son bord est
votée tout le monde connaît le titanic
il allait partir sur son voyage
inaugural c'était le plus grand navire
du monde
le paquebot le plus luxueux jamais
construit que l'on appelait
l'insubmersible tout premier voyage
il accueillait les gens les plus riches
et célèbres d'angleterre des états unis
les pipoles de lille il fut construit à
belfast en irlande pour rivaliser avec
ses prédécesseurs le lusitania et le
maurétania à son bord toutes étaient de
très grande qualité des draps 9 jusqu'à
la porcelaine d'une finesse rarissime le
titanic
tout comme ses frères l'olympic et un
peu plus tard le britannique était conçu
pour devenir les bateaux les plus grands
et les plus luxueux qui ait jamais
navigué de nos jours son coût de 6
millions d'euros n'est que de la petite
monnaie comparé à celui d'un boeing 787
dreamliner mais à l'époque c'est un très
lourd investissement pour le géant de la
banque us jp morgan la compagnie rivale
cunard avait déjà imposer un standard en
termes de vitesse avec des paquebots
comme le maurétania il établissait des
records de vitesse pour la traversée
entre southampton et new york
la white star line décide de répliques
et non pas en termes de vitesse mais en
bâtissant des paquebots plus grand et
plus luxueux
aucun autre bâtiment avant eux de cette
façon ils pouvaient embarquer un plus
grand nombre de passagers fortunés et
faire payer plus cher les grandes suites
destiné à accueillir des familles et
leurs domestiques
le fait de qualifier ce bateau d'un
submersible a été dicté par l'orgueil
qui pourrait sans doute sa source dans
la situation économique difficile de
l'époque on aurait peut-être le même
orgueil aujourd'hui et c'est le point de
départ de l'histoire du titanic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la traversée inaugurale par de thornton
le 10 avril 1912 à destination de new
york avec à son commandement le
capitaine edward j smith space est un
vétéran de la marine très respecté et
son voyage sur le titanic est censé être
le tout dernier de sa carrière il ya ici
du capitaine smith sait que ce bateau
était presque trop gros pour lui c'est
une mission vraiment énorme il a pris le
commandement du titanic pour son tout
dernier voyage avant de prendre sa
retraite et l'inimaginable s'est produit
en haut de la hiérarchie directement
sous le capitaine smith se trouve henri
wide commandant en second et william
murdoch premier officier wide et murdoch
étaient des officiers expérimentés wide
était au commandement du navire frère du
titanic l'olympique avant d'être nommé
officier en chef sur la traversée
inaugurale du titanic
ces navires sont comparables à des
villes flottantes et les préparatifs du
départ sont donc complexe et minutieux
surtout pour un premier voyage les
dernières provisions et des cargaisons
entières de bagages sont embarqués
puis arrivent les centaines de membres
d'équipage les officiers les pompiers
les stewards les cuisiniers les
infirmières les musiciens les garçons
d'ascenseur les coiffeurs les boulangers
et laveur de vitres et les matelots
l'agitation règne dès l'aube andrews
embarqué à 6h30 le matin du départ fait
le tour du bateau pendant six heures
l'inspecteur et prenant des notes avant
de confirmer que le bateau est
impeccable et prêts à partir
le titanic a été construit pour
effectuer de nombreuses traversées entre
southampton et new york voyage très
lucratif pour les paquebots grâce au
nombre de passagers concernés soixante
années connu pour beaucoup de choses
mais surtout pour ses paquebots et bien
entendu cela remonte à l'époque du
titanic il y a environ un siècle le
titanic fait deux escales à cherbourg
la plupart des passagers américains de
première classe embarque pour rentrer
chez eux après avoir fait un tour de
l'europe avant de se lancer dans
l'atlantique vers le destin qu'on lui
connaît le titanic s'arrête à queenstown
ancien nom de club dans le comté de cork
en irlande
c'est là que des centaines de passagers
de l'entrepont et de la troisième classe
monte tabor
beaucoup d'entre eux ont vendu tout ce
qu'ils avaient pour se payer un billet
vers une nouvelle vie
[Musique]
ce qui est fascinant sur le titanic
c'est la variété des passagers à bord
c'est une vraie ville flottante
transportant des gens de toutes classes
sociales
aujourd'hui il est difficile d'imaginer
la rigidité des frontières qui
existaient entre les classes à la fin de
l'époque édouardienne et au début du
règne de george 5 et de la reine mary le
film est comme un instantané d'une
époque
cal est le produit de cette société
d'une classe sociale élevée il fait
partie d'une grande famille son père est
un grand nom de l'industrie de l'acier à
philadelphie il a appris les coutumes et
le comportement de sa classe sociale et
la psychologie d'une époque dont il
réalise soudain qui est en train de
sombrer il sortait au sens figuré et en
l'occurrence au sens propre aussi mais
il se rend compte un peu tard au moment
où sa fiancée découvre soudain sa vraie
personnalité
à cette époque là c'est incompréhensible
ce film parle d'amour profond mais à
l'époque cette définition de l'amour
n'entrait pas dans ligne de cou et
malheureusement pour lui c'est un autre
homme qui en a profité
[Musique]
la société a connu de grands changements
au cours du siècle dernier elle s'est
mélangé après deux guerres mondiales et
une grande dépression une vision plus
humaine de la vie a balayé l'idée que
les gens sont voués à obéir aux limites
de la vie dans laquelle ils sont nés de
nos jours la qualité du service fourni
lors d'un voyage dépend du prix que l'on
paye plus que de la valeur sociale de
notre famille mais pour les passagers du
titanic
tout d'abord est dicté par leur classe
sociale le prix du billet dépend
cependant de la taille de la suite dans
laquelle les familles voyage certains
ont réservé les suite comprenant une
salle à manger privée ainsi que des
pièces à vivre et plusieurs chambres à
coucher pour eux et leurs domestiques
les prix pouvaient aller de 60 à 2 160
livres
cette somme semble faible de nos jours
mais ce serait l'équivalent de plusieurs
milliers d'euros aujourd'hui c'est
logement digne d'un palace sont ornés de
panneaux de bois décorées de meubles
coûteux et autres éléments décoratifs
alors qu'en troisième classe les
chambres ressemblent plutôt à des
dortoirs la liste des passagers du
titanic va des gens les plus riches aux
gens les plus pauvres ce qui rend cette
histoire aussi fascinante
c'est sans doute la diversité des
passagers qui se trouvent tous sur le
titanic pour des raisons différentes
le système de classes qui règne à
l'époque explique le fait que les
passagers de classes différentes ne soit
jamais en contact sur le bateau à part
peut-être cours des dernières heures de
la vie du titanic
certaines des personnalités les plus en
vue de l'époque se trouvent d'abord en
première classe
parmi eux le millionnaire john jacob
astor iv et son épouse madeleine force
astor l'industriel benjamin guggenheim
le propriétaire du grand magasin macy's
isidore strauss son épouse ida et une
millionnaire de denver
margaret brawn surnommé l'insubmersible
molly pour avoir aidé les autres
passagers au cours du naufrage le
banquier jpmorgan était censé faire
partie de la traversée inaugurale mais a
annulé au dernier moment
le voyage inaugural d'un grand paquebot
de luxe fait partie à l'époque des
petits bonus de la vie les richesses et
le luxe sont très en vogue pendant l'âge
d'or du début du xxème siècle passagers
de première classe devait sans doute
porter voici le genre de choses qu'on
devait voir sur ces gens en première
classe
les passagers et particulièrement les
dames voulait faire honneur au luxe
environnants en se parent de leurs plus
beaux atours les roms mettaient en
valeur la poitrine était plus fluide à
partir des hanches ou affiner la taille
mais ensuite dans les années 20 est
apparue la taille basse ou la silhouette
empire l habillement des hommes étaient
très traditionnel avec une veste en
tweed assez élégante des gilets des
chemises à ses alliés et à foulard les
passagers de première classe sont peut
être au courant de la présence à bord
des titres et seule une correspondante
de mode très connu aux états unis qui
voyagent avec des malles remplies
d'articles de mode français destiné à
ses clients américaine plus tard elle
s'est même souvenu de ce qu'elle portait
au moment de l'évacuation du navire si
j'étais en première classe habillée
comme ça serait évidemment pas pour
aller en salle de bal ses danses porte
un costume vous soyez en costume ou en
queue de pie avec un chapeau bien sûr
vous porteriez aussi des gants des
souliers impeccablement cirées ce genre
de choses
quant aux femmes elles portait une robe
de bal ou une robe du soir
c'était pas que même des gens plutôt
pauvre portait des vêtements très bien
taillés et monde avait un tailleur
j'imagine que la différence était dans
la qualité des tofs et dans le tissu
utilisé en 2e classe se trouvent les
personnes ayant atteint la réussite et
la duchesse par leur travail des
commerçants comme par exemple des
mineurs des professeurs ou des employés
de bureau les tarifs en deuxième place
varient entre 13 et 79 livre de l'époque
je pense que les critiques le film
repose surtout sur les événements la
chronologie
parce qu'en matière de costumes c'était
très pertinents historiquement toutes
les références sont là bas personne
chargée des costumes a vraiment fait un
boulot formidable pour moi les costumes
sont un aspect clé pour créer une époque
certains aspects c'est une grosse
responsabilité
oui on voit dans les costumes une
ambiance de la société mais aussi la
différence des classes on se distingue
tous d'un autre abîme ans donc je suis
sûr que même pour les acteurs du film
c'était primordial pour entrer dans
leurs personnages pour les aider à se
mettre dans un certain état d'esprit
absolument il faut garder à l'esprit
qu'il y avait 900 figurants habillés
oui ça fait du mans tous les jours
[Musique]
en troisième place se trouve plutôt des
familles cherchant à migrer vers les
etats unis une venue de suède d'irlande
de belgique et d'angleterre
dans la plupart des cas ils ont vendu
tout ce qu'ils avaient pour se payer la
traversée sur le titanic et garder un
peu d'argent pour leur nouvelle vie en
amérique
la plupart d'entre eux partent rejoindre
des proches déjà établis dans des villes
comme philadelphie et chicago
il existe différentes options de
logement en troisième classe
le prix moyen pour un billet est de 7
livres mais beaucoup voyage grâce à un
billet familiale coûtant entre 25 et 40
livres
l'exemple parfait et la famille cook de
suède
williams et ana skoog vivait dans le
michigan avec leurs quatre enfants
mais on souhaitait rentrer en suède mais
il regretter leur décision et ont décidé
de retourner aux états unis leur enfant
avait 11 9 5 et 2 ans laisse cook avait
également convaincu deux de leurs
proches de partir avec eux tous sont
morts dans le naufrage
tous ces gens est effective des
circonstances les victimes du titanic
ont payé leurs billets et mal leur en a
pris
à bord du navire
on ne peut que s'émerveiller de la
construction et de l'aménagement
c'est un vrai palace flottant la
décoration dans les appartements du
titanic est une réplique des différents
styles d'antan le fameux grand escalier
et de style williams et mairie mais la
rampe et de style louis xiv la salle à
manger et la salle de réception de la
première classe sont de style jacques
aubé 1
le restaurant de style louis saez le
salon de style louis 15 la salle de
lecture de style géorgien tardif et le
fumoir de style début géorgien
les personnes chargées du bon
fonctionnement du bateau dans la
hiérarchie de l'équipage sont les
suivants les ingénieurs assistant les
mécaniciens de pont et le personnel de
la salle des moteurs qui alimente les
fourneaux et entretiennent le feu
un assistant mécanicien de pont gagne 9
à 10 livres par mois
votre grand oncle était sur le titanic
il travaillait en première classe et
illzach et moi un peu toutes les
personnes qui travaillent ou peut-être
ouvriers sur les chantiers navals ou
bien travaillé sur les paquebots du
steward ou le reste de l'équipage
c'est ce que faisait mon oncle c'était
tout ça il avait travaillé sur plusieurs
grands paquebots avant d'embarquer sur
le titre c'était un grand moment de sa
vie jean parquet sur ceux subis de la
vire en tant que steward en chef de
première classe
c'était censé être l'apogée de sa
carrière il avait sûrement été dans des
pubs qui compte et ça laisse en vente et
en disant ça y est je suis au sommet et
puis on connaît la suite pour nourrir
les passagers le service de
l'avitaillement est composé de boulanger
de bouche et de cuisinier de porter deux
garçons d'office de magasinier c'est à
eux qu'incombe la tâche de nourrir de
satisfaire les plus de mille passagers
pour les passagers de première classe
la white star line souhaite offrir un
service de même qualité que dans les
meilleurs restaurants parisiens le
personnel chargé du service dans le
restaurant de première classe doit être
très bien formés et déjà avoir une
grande expérience
l'équipage compte aussi beaucoup de
professions diverses n'entrant dans
aucune catégorie particulière le titanic
et l'olympique étaient les premiers
paquebots à proposer des installations
comme des piscines des bains turcs et
les terrains de squash
il fallait donc employer des moniteurs
et des surveillants pour ses activités
il ya également les musiciens de
l'orchestré les opérateurs radio et
différents membres affectés aux ménages
[Musique]
entre le mois de novembre 1911 et la
traversée du titanic 20 bateaux ont
coulé au large des côtes de terre-neuve
l'hiver est rude et même une fois le
printemps arrive et il reste une
quantité inhabituelle de glace aux
alentours de l'île plus d'un millier
d'icebergs dérive vers le sud jusqu'au
grand banc l'équipage du titanic est
averti de la présence d'icebergs sur sa
trajectoire
d'ailleurs un cargos naviguant dans la
direction inverse émet un avertissement
radio au moment de croiser le titanic le
samedi 13 avril au soir
vers midi le lendemain le capitaine
smith prend connaissance d'un message
émis par le baltic un autre paquebot de
la white star line pour prévenir de la
grande quantité de glace
et comme on le voit dans le film de
james cameron
les icebergs ne sont pas une priorité
sur le titanic
[Musique]
un cargo à vapeur l'america prévient
également de la présence de gros iceberg
sur la trajectoire du titanic
mais les opérateurs radio sur les
techniques sont employés par marconi et
principalement payer pour transmettre
des messages entre les passagers ils
sont donc peu attentif à d'éventuelles
message à transmettre au commandement
le soir du drame la lune n'est pas
visible dans le ciel dégagé
les températures sont très basses et
l'océan et lisse et calme le capitaine
smith
en réponse aux avertissements d'icebergs
qu'il a reçu au cours des jours
précédents a dessiné une nouvelle
trajectoire passant un peu plus au sud
on dit qu'il se met à pousser smith a
modifié la trajectoire afin d'arriver à
bon port la veille de la date prévue et
faire sensation dans le monde entier
comme on le sait le titanic fera bien la
une des journaux et pour d'autres
raisons
à 23h40 les guetteurs aperçoivent à
l'oeil nu un énorme iceberg juste en
face de la proue du bateau
il sonne immédiatement trois coups de
cloche murdoch ordonne alors machine
arrière barababord douteux afin de
rectifier leur trajectoire pour éviter
l'iceberg
toutefois il est déjà trop tard
le paquebot des vies lentement sur la
gauche mais pas suffisamment pour éviter
ce qui semble être d'abord un simple
accroc sur le côté il s'agit en fait
d'une collision grave qui finira par
entraîner le naufrage du bateau en
quelques heures
principal défaut du bateau c'était un
problème de gestion qui concernait le
capitaine il n'a pas fourni de jumelles
aux vigies du ni de plan il ne voyait
rien très calme
l'eau ne faisait aucun bruit contre
l'iceberg
ils n'ont pas eu le temps de le voir
avant d'être juste devant
le géant de glace écorche la coque du
bateau à tribord du côté droit
percé la coque en plusieurs endroits et
fait sauter les rives et de la coque
sous la surface de l'eau cette collision
provoque des entrées d'eau dans les six
premiers compartiment l'impact en
lui-même a duré environ dix secondes la
montagne de glace disparaît ensuite dans
l'obscurité
mais le destin tragique du titanic est
déjà scellé
on suppose aujourd'hui que si le titanic
n'avait pas du tout dévié et avait
heurté l'iceberg de plein fouet et de
face la violence de l'impact aurait été
absorbée par la coque plus solide à la
proue et la collision n'auraient touché
qu'un ou deux compartiments à l'avant
mais au lieu de ça le coup latéral sur
le côté tribord du paquebot a fait céder
la coque au niveau des six premiers
compartiment bien plus que prévu par les
concepteurs du bateau important de
l'histoire on continuera à parler du
naufrage du titanic
parce qu'il s'agit d'un drame plus d'un
millier de personnes
inutilement trouvé la mort dans cette
catastrophe à cause de décisions prises
par l'équipage à l'époque le capitaine
spis alerté par le choc de l'impact
montre commandes et ordonne l'arrêt
complet du bateau murdoch ordonne
aussitôt la fermeture des portes
étanches et dix minutes après la
collision les cinq compartiments avant
sont inondés sous quatre mètres dos les
cinquième et sixième compartiment rempli
d'eau alourdissent la proue du bateau
provoquant d'autres entrées d'eau l'eau
commence alors à envahir de 7e
compartiment en passant au dessus des
cloisons de séparation
rapidement les alarmes sonnent les
portes étant se ferment les pompiers et
les mécaniciens lutte pour maintenir la
pression des machines à vapeur faire
fonctionner les pompes et garder les
lumières allumées
le capitaine suisse envoie thomass
andrews constater les dégâts le verdict
de ce dernier est aussi glacial que la
nuit qui les enveloppent le navire ne
pourra pas rester à flot de plus de
quelques heures les passagers et
l'équipage ont senti la collision mais
c'est surtout au silence au moment de
l'arrêt des moteurs que les passagers
encore éveillés comprenne qu'il se passe
quelque chose à ce moment là personne ne
panique
les passagers sont persuadés d'être en
sécurité sur cette ville flottante par
une nuit étoilée sur une mer d'huile
mais sous la surface de l'eau la coque
est ouverte
l'océan s'engouffre dans le navire et
menace désormais la salle des machines
les passagers de l'entrepont sont les
premiers à subir l'atrocité de la
situation peu avant minuit près de 20
minutes après la collision les sections
avant de la troisième place commencent à
être inondées sur le pont le capitaine
smith a déjà ordonné l'ouverture des
canots de sauvetage et l'embarquement
des femmes et des enfants
pour apaiser la terreur des passagers
l'orchestré reçoit l'ordre de jouer
quelques airs afin d'aider à la
tentative d'évacuation
[Musique]
jake phillips et harold pride opérateur
radio commence à envoyer le signal
international de détresse sécu des pour
comme cris danger' plusieurs navires le
reçoivent dont le paquebot jumeau du
titanic
l'olympique en plus du traditionnel sécu
des philips envoie également un sos
nouveau signal de détresse
malgré leur assurance d'arrivée tous les
navires qui reçoivent l'appel sont trop
loin pour atteindre le titanic avant
qu'il ne coule le navire le plus proche
et le cac repasse ya qui devrait mettre
quatre heures à arriver
mais il est trop petit et arrivera trop
tard comme le prouvera l'histoire
[Musique]
les mauvaises décisions ont été prises à
l'époque par le capitaine qui était
fautif mais surtout par le constructeurs
du paquebot le carpates ya qui était le
plus de roche aurait dû venir à leur
secours
le problème c'est que le titanic n'avait
pas de fusées de détresse rouge
il n'y en avait que des blanches ils ont
envoyé les fusées les autres navires qui
était suffisamment près pour venir
sauver les victimes ont simplement cru
qu'il se faisait une fête avec des feux
d'artifice
on aurait dû éviter ce drame depuis le
poste de commande on aperçoit les
lumières d'un navire à bâbord l'identité
de ce bateau demeure un mystère mais
certaines théories suppose qu'il
s'agissait peut-être du ss californian
ou du sam sonne un balinais norvégien ce
bateau ne répondront pas aux appels
radio le quatrième officier box hall et
le quartier-maître rouve tente de les
avertir de leur présence par des signaux
lumineux puis des fusées de détresse
mais le bateau ne répondra jamais le
californien a également rapporté avoir
aperçu des lumières au loin mais sa
radio était éteinte pour la nuit
en fait juste avant que l'opérateur
radio du californian quitte son poste
vers 23 heures
il avait tenté d'avertir le titanic de
la présence d'icebergs dans sa direction
mais la communication a été coupée
occupé par la transmission de messages
en retard entre les passagers philips a
renvoyé une réponse agressive la ferme
je suis occupée
le temps passe avant que les passagers
ne réalise la gravité de la situation
ils sont pour la plupart habillés pour
la soirée ou pour la nuit
ils sont en pyjama en costume en robe de
chambre ou en robe de soirée
tout cela ajoute au manque de réalisme
de la scène on aurait cru un numéro
destiné à divertir des passagers se
souvient un survivant mais la situation
prend tout son sens lorsque les canucks
ont mis à l'eau et les passagers réalise
alors qu'ils ne retourneront pas prendre
le thé dans leur luxueuse suite plus
tard les rapports des surveillants
témoigneront d'une grande panique à bord
et de l'incompétence de l'équipage après
la sortie du film de james cameron
la famille de l'officier william murdoch
certains historiens et certains
habitants des d'albicy en écosse ville
natale de murdoch n'ont pas apprécié le
personnage de murdoch dans le film celui
ci se tue d'une balle dans la tête après
avoir tiré sur deux passagers qui
cherchait à rejoindre un canot de
sauvetage
grâce aux déclarations de témoins
survivants
les historiens ont la quasi certitude
qu'un officier s'est effectivement
suicider mais ils ne peuvent affirmer
qu'il s'agissait bien du premier
officier murdoch de représentants de la
production ont donc été envoyé dans la
ville de murdoch
ils ont présenté leurs excuses et on
fait une donation de 8500 $ au fonds
commémoratif de murdoch
[Musique]
la plupart des femmes et des enfants
sont embarqués dans les canots de
sauvetage
dans une atmosphère de confusion et de
panique au moment du naufrage certain
stewart garde les grilles fermées tandis
que d'autres laissent les femmes et les
enfants montés jusqu'au pont supérieur
en raison du manque de communication
entre les ponts des différents niveaux
tout le monde n'a pas conscience de la
gravité de la situation les membres
d'équipage ne cherche même pas à
récupérer les passagers dans les
cabinets les parties communes et le fait
que certains passagers de troisième
classe ne parle pas anglais pose
également problème
par conséquent la plupart des passagers
de troisième classe restent livrés à eux
mêmes seuls 25 % d'entre eux survivront
à la catastrophe
la plupart des hommes qui ont survécu au
ressenti du grand d'europe 1 il ya
l'histoire d'un homme qui s'est fait
jeter dehors de chez lui par sa propre
mère semble-t-il qui le traitait de
lâche parce qu'il avait survécu a
raconté cette histoire un ami lors de la
commémoration python content de moi
c'est un homme m'a tapé sur l'épaule
il avait l'air contrarié visiblement pas
qu il m'a dit qu'ils ont écouté mon
grand père est un survivant il n'était
pas un lâche
on vient donner l'heure de monter dans
un canon pour aider les femmes et vous
devriez raconter ça m'a fait réaliser
que même sans temps plus tard ici à
southampton
on plaisante pas avec le titre
des centaines de passagers et deux
membres d'équipage sont alors livrés à
eux mêmes au milieu de l'eau avec un
simple gilet de sauvetage pour les
maintenir à la surface
les personnes qui ont eu la chance de
rentrer dans un canot de sauvetage
entendent les cris terrifiant
s'affaiblir jusqu'à ce que seul le
silence règne sur la nuit calme et
étoiles et dans les canaux les
survivants assiste aux derniers instants
du titanic à la surface toutes lumières
encore allumé et entendent leur
qu'istres jusqu'au bout
les opérateurs radio eux aussi restent à
leur poste jusqu'au dernier moment pour
transmettre les appels de détresse aux
navires proche et lointain lorsque le
capitaine du carpathia arthur rostron
parvient enfin aux coordonnées auquel le
titanic se trouvait il n'y trouve que
l'étendue de l'océan couvertes de débris
du naufrage lors de l'aménagement du
bateau il tenait avait décidé d'agrandir
la salle à manger et le pont des classes
supérieures
par conséquent il n'y avait plus assez
de place pour les trente deux canots de
sauvetage nécessaire quand j'ai vu au
départ il n'y avait donc que c'est ce
qu'annonce etc ce qui veut dire que
seule la moitié des passagers soit 2200
personnes auraient pu être sauvées
rostron trouve aussi les canots de
sauvetage et accueille à son bord les
passagers et cuisez qui se souviendront
plus tard du sentiment de gratitude
ressenti à la vue des projecteurs du
carpathia à l'horizon le bateau arrivera
à new york avec 705 survivants 1500 vies
ont été perdues dans l'océan
[Musique]
et pourtant les gens et les médias
croyait le titanic à submersible dans un
article de magazine un rédacteur la
qualifier de pratiquement un submersible
à cause de sa double coque de ses portes
étanches aucun autre bateau n'était
équipé de telles installations à
l'époque censé permettre au navire de
rester à flot en cas d'avarié le temps
de rentrer au port
la white star line n'a toutefois jamais
utilisé le terme
insubmersible dans sa campagne de
promotion à l'époque en outre personne
n'a jamais prononcé la phrase dieu
lui-même ne pourrait pas coulé ce bateau
ce n'est qu'une réplique que james
cameron a ajouté à son film pour
exprimer le sentiment de sécurité
éprouvée par les passagers en montant
sur le titanic
[Musique]
il y avait plusieurs raisons qui
pourraient expliquer le naufrage des
choix ont été faits dans le but de
limiter le budget par le comité
décisionnaires de la white star line
l'une des décisions prises pour réduire
les coûts fut d'utiliser ce dérivé en
faire au lieu de river en acier
l'arrivée en acier ne rit pas sous l'eau
contrairement au river en fait de plus
l'épaisseur des plaques de la coque a
été réduite
quand le bateau a heurté un iceberg
latéral manquer les plaques n'ont pas
résisté comme elle aurait dû le faire
les têtes dérivés ont sauté au moment de
l'impact les plaques ont cédé et c'est
pour ça que l'eau a pu s'engouffrer de
la sorte quand on analyse ce drame
on se pose de questions d'abord pourquoi
le bateau at-il school et quand il a
heurté l'iceberg
et pourquoi y at il eu stand 12e
[Musique]
les naufrages ont toujours été une
source de fascination depuis le moyen
âge ce mot évoque des images de
piraterie de pillage d'or et deux joyaux
et l'histoire d'un autre âge
on ne peut imaginer une vision plus
exaltantes que celle d'une épave immergé
pendant un siècle remontant à la surface
pour la première fois et même en
considérant les nombreux trésors de
l'histoire
il existe peu d'épaves ayant attiré plus
de convoitise que celle du titanic
contrairement au maire les roses il est
impossible de remettre à flot l'épave du
titanic l'espoir de renflouer un jour un
navire intact a disparu lorsque l'épave
a été découverte il ya 25 ans depuis la
découverte du titanic
l'image la plus marquante du bateau est
désormais celle de sap rouille et
émergents de la vase le plus gros
problème avec les petits-enfants
submersible c'est leur visibilité à de
telles profondeurs et très noir
les phares quand on est 300 et 600
mètres de profondeur
on ne distingue plus rien au delà des
six a dit m c'est un peu comme si vous
étiez en voiture sur l'autoroute et que
vous ne voyez qu à six mètres de
distance
la première vraie tentative pour
localiser l'épave du titanic est financé
par jacques grimes un riche texan en été
1981 il engage deux des plus grands
océanographes du monde pour mener les
recherches
l'expédition par de port everglades en
floride
malgré les rapports de témoins en 1912
le titanic c'est bien cassé en deux au
moment de sombrer alors que de l'avis
général il était resté intact
l'expédition ratisse une large zone
autour des coordonnées d'où le titanic
avait envoyé ses appels de détresse mais
en vain
le projet ralenties par le mauvais temps
et les défaillances matérielles une
seconde tentative l'année suivante passe
à trois kilomètres de l'épave juste hors
de portée des sonars jack grimm croit
avoir découvert l'une des hélices du
titanic
mais une troisième expédition révèle
qu'elle est trop petit pour appartenir
au fameux paquebot et clichy le plus
gros danger dans une épave c'est de
rester coincé il suffit de s'en mêler
dans un câble de se cogner dans un
morceau d'épave de faire céder à un
plancher de coincer une corde dans une
église du sous marin
et dans ce cas là vous êtes perdus
lorsque plusieurs centaines de mètres de
profondeur qui va venir vous chercher
la consigne est essentielle c'est de
rester très prudent
en l'été 1985 une opération conjointe
est lancée entre une équipe
océanographique française et une équipe
américaine sous le commandement du
docteur robert ballard l'équipe passent
plus de trois semaines à ratisser la
zone connue sous le nom de titanic
canyon le 1er septembre 1985 le
scientifique ce tout à riespach bien
obtenir la première image avérée du
titanic
depuis 73 ans dans son livre la
découverte du titanic
ballard écrit les yeux de ce tous
étaient rivés sur le moniteur il y a
quelque chose at il dit en désignant
l'écran est en pleine nuit
tous les membres d'équipage étaient
soudain complètement réveillé l'élément
qui ressemblait à une chaudière est
comparée aux photos de 1911 des
chaudières du titanic sur les chantiers
de perlando wolf
il s'agit bien d'un titanic de
l'expédition pass 4 jours de plus à
prendre des images de l'épave
avant de rentrer à wall pour diffuser
les photos dans les médias qui les
attendait ballard déclare qu'il avait
complètement sous-estimé l'excitation
que provoquerait la découverte de
l'épave et la soif d'imagés
d'informations
depuis ce moment historique
l'effervescence règne pour photographier
et fouillé l'épave du titanic
ici au quartier général de la société
océane futur le légendaire jean michel
cousteau travaille dur pour préserver
les sites marins à travers le monde
comment protéger quelque chose si on ne
le comprend pas mon père disait les gens
protègent ce qu'ils aiment
moi je dis si on comprends pas comment
peut-on protéger
c'est à ça que sert ocean futures faire
comprendre et à communiquer cette
information aux gens il ne s'agit pas de
voler un miroir ou de prendre un objet
c'est un manque de respect pour les gens
qui étaient là pour l'environnement qui
les entoure et pour le fait qu'en effet
il y a bien de la vie sous-marine et on
devra laisser cette vie tranquille c'est
tout en s'imposant en prenant le moindre
objet on a un véritable impact direct
sur la morale on se doit d'avoir
en ce qui concerne le respect de l'autre
et tout tient en cette phrase simple
show protégeant les océans
on se protège soi même
[Musique]
depuis les premières plongées beaucoup
d'objets et de morceaux du bateau ont
été remontés à la surface pour être
exposé au public
la plupart de ces objets sont toujours
visibles au musée national de la marine
à greenwich en angleterre qui était
présent lorsque le tout premier objet du
titanic a été remonté à la surface
il m'a dit je les tenues dans ma main
janvier je suis tombé à genoux et j'ai
pleuré
c'est ça la vraie passion pour le
titanic le musée national de la marine a
été officiellement fondée par une loi en
1934 est ouvert au public par le roi
georges 6 le 27 avril 1937
on peut y voir la maison de la reine du
xviie siècle et depuis les années 50
l'observatoire royal de greenwich les
bâtiments du musée ont ouvert en 1805
tout d'abord comme école pour les
enfants de marins
ce musée compte désormais les biens les
plus importants du monde dans l'histoire
marine de l'angleterre
parmi les pièces exposées récupérés dans
des épaves on trouve des valises des
instruments de musique des bouteilles de
champagne au bouchon intacte du matériel
de navigation des chaussures des
chapeaux et même des flacons de parfum
ayant gardé leurs fragrances film de
james cameron est extraordinaire je l'
ai adoré il a pris quelques libertés
les films ne peuvent être entièrement
filiale à l'histoire est d'ailleurs
l'histoire elle même n'est jamais
complètement fidèle à la réalité
nous passons le plus clair de notre
temps à la rue visiter et à la voir sous
des angles nouveaux
cela n'a jamais été aussi vrai que pour
l'histoire fascinante du titanic qu'on
voulait essayer de descendre pour
tourner un film narratif
c'était une expérience inouïe de
descendre à 4 mm de profondeur avec une
pression énorme et des moyens
technologiques nécessaires incroyable
tout en espérant y arriver et qu'on y
est arrivé
c'est vraiment fantastique au cours de
ces premières recherches pour le film
james cameron a décidé de filmer la
vraie épave du titanic est d'incorporer
ces images dans son film de fiction
titanic c'est mon bébé
donc évidemment je voulais me relever
les manches et m'impliquer à chaque
étape du processus
le titanic a sombré à une profondeur de
plus de 3800 mètres près de 4 km sous la
surface de l'océan le plus traître de la
planète
il n'existe que cinq engins sous marins
au monde capable de descendre à une
telle profondeur
deux d'entre eux mir 1 et mir 2 se
trouvait sur un navire de recherche
russe l'académique qu'elle dit le
directeur scientifique russe chargé
duquel dish le docteur anatoly
sagalevitch était d'abord opposé un
usage si trivial de son navire de
recherche
toutefois la chute de l'union soviétique
avait rendu la situation économique
difficile et sagalevitch a fini par
accepter cette opportunité de faire
rentrer des dollars américains en
septembre 1995
cameron commence à filmer c'est plonger
sur l'épave du titanic loin sous la
surface de l'atlantique à une telle
profondeur
la pression de l'eau est 400 fois
supérieure à la pression atmosphérique
la moindre défaillance sur la coque de
l'engin entraînerait la mort de tous ses
passagers
c'était une vraie mission pour la
première fois on allait descendre filmé
dans l'environnement le plus extrême ou
un film ait jamais été tourné sur une
maquette de l'épave en rassemblant les
connaissances de tous les meilleurs
spécialistes pour le reproduire à
l'identique jusqu'au moindre détail de
la forme des vastes un gage on a
embarqué sur le bateau ruche qui change
avec cette maquette pour pouvoir
visualiser les plans on avait une petite
caméra montée sur un sous marin
miniature avec des petits projecteurs
correspondant aux frais et on est comme
ça
les plans qu'on voulait tourner sous
l'eau je demandais aux pilotes russes de
déplacer ces petits sous-marins
exactement comme il le ferait ensuite
avec pour qu'ils comprennent ce qu'on
voulait finir on voulait essayer de
descendre je fais tourner un film
narratif
c'était une expérience incroyable je me
sens à l'aise de profondeur avec une
pression énorme et des moyens
technologiques nécessaires
incroyable tout en espérant y arriver et
on y est arrivé c'est vraiment
fantastique
[Musique]
cameron a effectué 12 plongé à haut
risque mais les circonstances diverses
longtemps empêché d'obtenir les images
de grande qualité qui l'espéraient les
séquences des films tournés depuis le
sous-marin sont une combinaison d'effets
visuels filmé sur la maquette et de
plans de la vraie est pas du titanic
filmer sous l'eau le plan tourné avec
effets spéciaux sont vraiment impeccable
il devait être parfait puisque on allait
les juxtaposer avec les vraies vidéos
pour tourner ces plantes on a équipé les
caméras de films et on a rempli la pièce
de fumée pour faire apparaître le rayon
de lumière et nous parle du sous marin
est comme ça ça donne l'illusion qu'on
est vraiment sous l'eau pour
reconstituer le titanic
il a fallu plus de 1500 tonnes d'acier
30000 river 15000 planches de
contreplaqué et plusieurs tonnes de
plâtre
tous ces matériaux ont été utilisés de
la même façon que lors de la
construction du vrai titanic en 1912 il
faut déjà avant de faire son film james
cameron a lu les rapports d'enquêté
anglais et américains il avait que
l'inde et stewart avait déclaré qu'un
couple avait forcé une porte et qui leur
avait crié c'est la propriété de la
white star line vous allez devoir
rembourser ça
sur lequel se réfugient rose est une
copie de l'original
finalement un film est assez fidèle à la
réalité la reconstitution du titanic de
james cameron a été construite presque à
l'échelle il a entièrement reconstruit
la coque d'acier rift et du côté tribord
duo jusqu'à la ligne de flottaison le
côté tribord a été choisi pour la
reconstitution
parce que les rapports météorologiques
indiqué que le vent dominant pendant la
traversée souffler du nord vers le sud
ce vent allait donc permettre de porter
la fumée des cheminées vers le côté
bâbord pour donner l'impression que la
reproduction immobile du bateau est en
fait en train d'avancer grâce à l'énorme
travail consacré à ce film ce qui marque
le plus les spectateurs restent la
romance entre les deux amants rose et
jack qui eux ont été complètement
inventé ce n'est pas l'histoire d'un
naufrage ce n'est pas un énième film sur
le titanic le titanic n'est que le décor
dès cette histoire 2013 ça a toujours
été ça pour moi toujours toujours je
voulais tellement que leo joue le rôle
de jack
je suis vraiment reconnaissante il était
génial avoue le tournage je me suis posé
des questions je me suis dit que ça
allait être dur
si je tombais amoureuse pour de vrai
j'appréhendais vraiment parce qu'il est
sublime on peut pas dire le contraire
il ne s'agit pas de simples faits deux
personnages du nombre de victimes ou de
canots de sauvetage
le film parle de la réalité émotionnelle
d'une expérience intense
le personnage de jack dawson est
librement inspiré de l'écrivain jack
london
dawson était en fait un mécanicien sur
le titanic qui est désormais enterrée à
halifax
la similitude des noms est un pur hasard
découvert après l'écriture du scénario
rose de whitby créateur est un
personnage entièrement inventé il n'y
avait pas non plus sur le titanic de
diamants appelé coeur de l'océan quand
j'ai appris que kate winslet avait été
choisi et je voulais la rencontre et
observer sa gestuelle et écouter sa voix
pour pouvoir jouer son personnage parce
que ce n'est pas mon voyage c'est le
site
on a ouvert une bouteille on a bavardé
et on a passé un très bon moment
vivo j'ai trouvé ça remarquable c'est
une femme admirable et elle a des
histoires extraordinaires a raconté
comme quand elle a travaillé avec les
marx brothers
elle est incroyable j'ai adoré le moment
qu'on a passé ensemble
j'espère lui ressembler à son âge je
pense que titanic prendre un nouveau
sens pour les gens qui l'ont vu il ya 15
ans
obs mais leur vie a changé ce sont
peut-être les mariés ont eu des enfants
et il porte désormais un autre regard
sur la vie l'amour y verront peut-être
moins la passion du romantisme est une
idée plus adolescentes
ils seront sans doute plus attentifs au
sens du devoir à la raison de notre
présence sur cette planète
ce que leur présentent les uns pour les
autres tu as tous ses aspects auxquels
un public plus âgé de se montrer plus
sensibles une autre histoire d'amour du
titanic a bien été inspirés de
personnages réels on voit dans le film
un couple de personnes âgées qui choisi
de mourir ensemble plutôt que d'être
séparés yz à aydat strauss propriétaire
du grand magasin macy's aurait pu monter
dans l'un des cas note il aida a refusé
de monter dans un canot tout temps qu'il
resterait des femmes à bord
ida elle refusa de quitter son mari des
témoins rapportent kida a dit à son mari
où que tu ailles je te suis
[Musique]
le film a permis à une nouvelle
génération de découvrir le mystère et la
fascination qui fait l'histoire du
titanic même la chanson de céline dion
mayence will go on a des aliments succès
dans le monde entier
ces paroles n'illustre pas seulement
l'histoire d'amour du film mais aussi
les émotions éprouvées par les personnes
présentes sur le bateau cette nuit là
[Musique]
partout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en hommage au centième anniversaire de
la traversée inaugurale du titanic
cameron a repris son film pour en sortir
une version en trois dimensions l'une
des seules façons possibles de rendre
hommage à une telle tragédie
c'est de ne jamais oublier ce qui s'est
passé et les souffrances que cela a
causé la seule consolation qu'on peut
avoir face à un tel drame
c'est de se dire qu'au moins on ne
l'oubliera jamais j'adore les histoires
inspirées de faits réels
c'est fascinant j'ai toujours voulu
petit annick ressortent sur grand écran
parce que c'est comme servir lieu d'être
on a commencé à réfléchir ou fait de
ressortir le film en 3d écoles chinoises
on s'est dit que le moment idéal pour ça
on serait le centenaire du titre il y
avait les pauvres dans les étages
inférieurs
et puis les riches et tous se battait
pour survivre on pourrait en faire
d'autres films
je peux aussi fantastique très
intéressant il m'est encore fascinés
pour ça toute cette histoire sans point
après c'est fascinant on s'en souvient
en plus du film d'autres hommages se
prépare pour le centenaire de cette
traversée légendaire le 31 mai 2011 tout
juste cent ans après la sortie de call
du titanic une fusée de détresse fut
tiraient depuis le chantier naval de
belfast en commémoration tous les
bateaux situés autour de aaron en wolof
ont fait sonner leurs cornes de brume et
la foule assemblée a applaudi pendant
soixante deux secondes le temps exact
qu'il a fallu aux paquebots pour sortir
de cale en 1912 le centenaire du titanic
éveil d'intérêt dans le monde entier en
partie grâce à ce fantastique dans
lequel vous avez joué un rôle superbe
film a créé un engouement énorme pour
cette histoire et a ravivé la
fascination du public pour ce géant des
vins
[Musique]
à 60 tonnes amusé sur le thème du
titanic navire vedette de la ville
ouvrira au moment du centenaire de la
tragédie les travaux ont commencé en
octobre dernier sur ce projet à 34
millions d'euros destinée à transformer
les anciens bâtiments du tribunal
d'instance pour en faire le nouveau
musée maritime de la ville guinéenne
perceur l'architecte de ce bâtiment où
se situera l'exposition sur le titanic
on est ici à l'entrée du bâtiment
le but de changer la nature du vêtement
fait partie du projet on a enlevé les
escaliers pour créer cet espace d'entrée
à trois ouvertures
quand on montera dans les galeries pour
suivre la visite on pourra s'arrêter
pour regarder par où on est entré ce
sera un point de repère permanence pour
se situer dans le bâtiment ou bien vous
m'avez parlé d'une reproduction du
titanic
tout à fait expliquez moi ce qu'on verra
sur cet immense mur
qu'est ce qu'il y aura on aura une
immense collection ensuite en avançant
dans l'exposition on traverse cette
passerelle comme monter à bord du
titanic
donc ici on est au point d'amarrage
numéro 44 alors à l'ouverture du musée
pour arriver jusqu'à l'exposition sur le
titanic il faudra monter par cet
escalier il n'est pas encore terminée il
faudra prendre cet escalier pour aller
voir les objets du titanic
ces chats et on arrivera dans le grand
hall qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
cette pièce sera la première salle
d'exposition par le grand hall
elle sera consacrée à l'embarquement
l'achat d'un billet pour le titanic le
rôle des différents employés
en avançant dans l'exposition on
arrivera dans cette salle sera destiné à
illustrer la vie à bord il y aura de
vrais coucher oui ce sera aménagée comme
une cabine de première classe
il y aura aussi la salle des moteurs
reproduire la salle des moteurs
oui restitue le décor des gens
traducteur on arrive ensuite dans cette
pièce beaucoup plus sombre maintien ici
une température un peu plus basse que
dans les autres salles
c'est la salle consacrée à la
catastrophe en est le mélange le moment
où le titanic a coulé on passe ensuite
dans la salle suivante liées aux
conséquences du naufrage le sol de cette
caisse sera recouvert d'un immense plan
de la vie de 60
je sais qu environ 500 avis à des
membres d'équipage britanniques vivait
dans la région du céou somson exactement
et cette seule l'on rendra hommage
chaque membre d'équipage originaires de
southampton sera représentée par un
repère sur la carte cette salle sera
consacrée à l' enquête qui a suivi le
drame
adacore l'enquète du gouvernement
britannique sur la white star line se
trouvaient les galeries pour le public
quand aura lieu l'ouverture début avril
pour le centenaire du naufrage
je suis sûr que ce retour au titanic va
intéresser de nombreux passionnés
je vous remercie qu'idéal merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
malgré quelques réticences de la part de
certaines familles de victimes
les visites et les événements continuent
de se multiplier la fascination pour le
titanic est plus forte que jamais leur
droit de l'atlantique où le navire a
sombré est aussi très fréquenté par les
compagnies de navigation qui profite de
cet engouement
deux d'entre elles organisent des
traversées suivant le trajet exact du
titanic et ses croisières affiche
complet de nombreux événements sont
organisés et de nouveaux livres vont
sortir
je pense que tout cela va alimenter
enthousiasme général et cet engouement
va encore durer d une autre compagnie de
navigation va encore plus loin en
organisant une expédition de 15 jours en
plongée sous marine entre les mois de
juin et d'août 2012 qui offrira aux fans
du titanic
l'occasion d'apercevoir l'épave du
titanic à plus de 3000 mètres de
profondeur sous l'océan
cette expérience controversée partira du
port de st john's à terre-neuve au
canada à moins de 550 kilomètres de
l'endroit où le titanic a sombré les
passionnés du titanic pourront ensuite
descendre en sous marin pour observer
l'épave
cette expérience rappelait permettra de
montrer au public comment cette histoire
véritable tragédie jeter passée dans le
domaine du divertissement
on cherche à expliquer la cause de cette
fascination inépuisable et s est presque
insatiable le rêver ce titanic était le
plus grand paquebot du monde et est
devenue l'une des catastrophes maritimes
les plus tragiques de l'histoire en
temps de paix pour l'angleterre
exaltée par sa supériorité impérial et
ses réussites dans l'industrie mécanique
durant l'ère victorienne
la tragédie du titanic porta un coup
direct à la belle assurance du pays et
de 20 pour toujours le symbole poignant
de l'imperfection de la technologie
moderne et de la supériorité
indiscutable de la nature sur l'homme à
la croisée des 40 degrés nord et des 54
degrés aux angoisses l'océan on se fait
sauvage et avant la mort et cube à la
pointe des flots pas une stèle base une
couronne ne marquera jamais l'endroit où
1500 hommes au perdu la vie mais
l'humanité n'a pas péri l'océan se sert
sans prêter l'object aux larmes ni à la
misère humaine
aucun ornement pour parer les tombes
marine ni de sol pour pleurer ses
victimes
nul n'est besoin de pierre de masse pour
garder le souvenir de l'endroit où deux
nobles hommes ont perdu la vie mais
l'humanité n'a pas péri il n'est jamais
aisé de nos rares même sous un ciel
étoilé aussi loin sa famille et de ses
amis dans un linceul de sombres détresse
perd une couronne pour ceindre le front
de l'homme et couvrir une ombre ancien
leur ira pour toujours sur les flots là
où l'humanité n'a pas péri
[Musique]
m
en
on
[Musique]
à